في الجبهة الجنوبية
لأوكرانيا ، يقودنا فريق استطلاع نحو
الخطوط الروسية
التي نسير فيها عبر الأشجار
لأنهم يخشون
أن يتم رصدنا من أعلى
بواسطة طائرات بدون طيار روسية ،
وهذه هي الطريقة التي يقومون بها بعملهم
هنا
مخبئين بالأشجار
وجهتنا طائرة بدون طيار  فريق محجوب
من السماء ،
مهمتهم العثور على القوات الروسية
واستدعاء ضربات المدفعية مشكلة
على الرغم من أنه في أول رحلة لهم في اليوم ،
تلاعبت الإجراءات المضادة الروسية بطائرتهم
بدون طيار ، حيث يحتاجون إلى تبديل الأجزاء
قبل الإطلاق التالي
، يكاد يكون من المستحيل محاربة
التشويش الروسي  أرسل إشارة
يقول القائد ولكن لدينا أجهزة خاصة
لمكافحتها ،
ولكن عندما تنطلق الطائرة بدون طيار ، فإنها تتأرجح
بالطريقة الخاطئة التي تضرب الأشجار.
ساحة المعركة
والخطأ الذي يرتكبه مشغلو الطائرات بدون طيار هؤلاء
يمكن أن يكلفهم
حياتهم في القاعدة على شاشة كبيرة يقومون
بالبحث في الرحلات الأولى
فيديو التفاصيل لا تصدق ، أعني أنه يمكنك
رؤية مكان المركبات بالضبط
في الأشجار ، المشغل مصور أخبار سابق يبلغ من العمر 24 عامًا ،
لذا فأنت
تنظر إلى الروس ولكن يمكنهم أن
ينظروا إليك عندما تكون في الميدان ،
نعم  كيف تشعر
أن هذا مخيف إلى أي مدى مخيف ولكنه
أمر مخيف للغاية ولكنك تستمر في فعل ذلك ، نعم
لماذا
جيدًا لأننا يجب أن نفعل ذلك
قرارات الحياة أو الموت التي
تستهدف الضربة لإنقاذ مواطنيه
أثناء قيادته له ليس لديه فكرة عن أن
طائرتك بدون طيار تتبع
لم يكن لديه أي فكرة في
الأيام السابقة عندما تجنبوا
الإجراءات المضادة الروسية ، فقد كان لديهم
حظ أفضل
عندما ضرب موقع دبابة روسية في الأسبوع الماضي
عندما استدعوا
ضربة مدفعية بينما كانوا يشاهدون
من سيفوز في حروب الطائرات بدون طيار هذه سيساعد في
تحديد من يسيطر على ساحة المعركة
وهذا يعتمد على من لديه أذكى
تقنية
ومن لديه أفضل
المهارات التقليدية في الخطوط الأمامية للاختباء منها
نيك روبرتسون سي إن إن في الجبهة الجنوبية
لأوكرانيا